[Applause]
um
because you probably came in new york
and you were at the tail end of like the
seller's heyday
right like the old guard at the cellar
you know patrice
i was 04 but when you actually started
hanging around those guys
yeah like did you befriend like were you
close with patrice at all
yeah yeah uh i used to sit in his car at
boston comedy club and so he went while
he was on stage
yeah because you couldn't park you know
right in front of boston yeah and so i
would
go it was in the car village when i was
yeah yeah it would have flipped over
okay so you were there when i was still
in boston yeah i barked there
i was that was my first barking thing in
the arctic too okay okay so
patrice was he ruthless to you
uh he was so the the i which i've talked
about it but like
he liked i learned quick to kind of just
whatever he
would think we i am i would just go with
it so like he would be like y'all not
believe in dinosaurs no
i'll be like yeah i don't yeah like i
would just say whatever he wanted you
know i've never thought about that ever
my life
like i've learned about dinosaurs like
but the fact that he thinks we didn't
i learned i was like well i'm yeah i was
like no we don't believe in dinosaurs i
would just go with it
right and uh so he was like very nice i
mean we would go to his house for
uh fourth of july the bar would come up
and like my wife would go over there and
then uh he was very nice to my wife and
he
uh because she would always like i don't
know like help clean up after something
he like loved that
yeah yeah and so i i uh patrice was
always very very cool i met him
i mean until the last day i would every
time i talked about like hey nate i'm
friends with big j
i would say that and like at the end
he'd be like you're like yeah dude i
know who you are you know but you're
like i don't know
you know he was uh he was the best
uh uh ever saw but i was at their fame
he was at uh burr and his hbo one night
stand taping you were you were there i
was there
holy [ __ ] and so okay let me just set
this up to everybody listening there is
like
an unbelievable bit that if you don't
watch the whole thing
i don't think it resonates the same way
the whole thing with the [ __ ] beam
mm-hmm
it was like what would you do if you got
in a horrible car accident where you
lost your [ __ ]
yeah you know that [ __ ] if you just see
that within like the clip online
it doesn't get the full effect because
there's like 20 minutes of build up
where the audience is kind of fighting
back and forth and they're laughing but
the same time some of the women the
artists are giving them some pushback
and they're looking at him like he's
this sexist and you're objectifying us
and all that
when he dropped that that's what also
for the record used to do half hour
comedy specials
and apparently they filmed burr and
patrice the same night
yeah so what so they did what was the
reaction and have you heard that bit
before or
i don't think not i i don't know if i
even like remember i won't remember that
specific
uh but then i remember them warming up
to it
like are we doing running their set
right yeah and uh it was
running at the boston uh i remember one
night i recorded
i timed patrice's set because it was
like they had to do a half hour yeah
yeah and so when he got done i was like
hey you did like 36 minutes
and i remember him being like all right
and then walked away from me and this is
like
because he wrote it as a favor for him
he didn't ask he no he didn't ask
no no not at all dude like he this was
like young comic
you know trying to do it i think i'm
supposed to do like i think
at that time well that you have it's
called a half hour so you have to do 30
exactly
i have no concept of editing or
like you know maybe you gotta do 29
minutes maybe 38 minutes like whatever
the concept it doesn't really matter
and i just and i'm like so i tell him
like thinking i'm helping him he's
you know i think he was like all right
man like he it did not matter at all
and so the funny thing with so i went i
went to one taping so the first tape
they did two tapings the first day being
burr went first patrice went second the
second attainment they would have
flipped yeah so i was at the bird first
patrice
yeah so what i remember the most about
it was
that was birds coming out and so when
burr went up
i mean dude i remember in that audience
this is when he's doing the horrible
it's hard to breathe
uh how are you going harlem yeah oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah
he's like you get like a white guy gets
up there 120 straight like ah you guys
have to breathe up here like
that so the shoes joke the dirty
sneakers yeah something like that yeah
i remember burr murdering so hard and i
remember
the audience uh it was just they didn't
know what they just saw
like he was so good that you could tell
that they were like yeah who was that
again
like you know because burt wasn't known
like he was
he was like people in comedy knew him
but he wasn't he wasn't
you know i went to caroline to watch him
and they closed the curtain at caroline
like he wasn't selling out and they just
he
he dude he murdered so hard and then i
think patrice actually after him
it took a minute had a tough time
following him yeah and i
i always say you don't have it's not
like patrice is not good enough to
follow him but
it's just the room has to switch the
room has to be
and they and burr murder and patrice
probably did it to burr
when they flipped but it i just remember
because burr i think was the one that
kind of you know patricia didn't really
go
crazy after that yeah he you know his
his elf in the room is what really
was the the i think that we were at that
oh yeah yeah
so that was unreal like uh but burrs
that bird to me that was
he did that and then the ona thing
happened right after that
i believe and then so then it was like
all right bird's gone
and then so then we then we go to
caroline's and that's when you know
you're like hey can we go watch and
they're like no no you can't go in no
room
and you're like ah it is kind of crazy
and i guess people listening right now
you're probably looking at most specials
and assuming everybody there
is a fan but back in the day before you
were popular you did a special when you
were kind of unknown
oh they would pay that tickets for free
they give tickets for free and they pay
them yeah wow so like all the comedy
central specials
have a half hour or the what was it even
the freemium
or something like that oh yeah even the
hours sometimes even hours
you don't have you can't sell a theater
out yeah like it's
you know so it's like yeah they're not
it's not like now now it's like you
don't get a special
unless you can sell out yeah that
theater yeah they just happen to be
taping your sold-out show
that's what the special is yeah that's
the best part is like now you can kind
of go like all right
i'll pick i'll go to that market anyway
and you sell tickets and you're like
let's just film this
yeah and then and then so you pick where
you want to film which is
it's much different you're in front of
your crowd and yeah uh but yeah then you
you have people they don't know why
they're there when you film
do you like being fish out of water
for a special for something you're
taping do you like being a little bit of
a fish out of water to that audience
like they know who you are they're
familiar with you but at the same time
they like the fact that you're a little
bit different
yeah or do you like being a home team
for a special specific yeah not just i
mean well the greatest you know one
thing seinfeld said a long time ago they
said
what the only thing that you miss like
before being famous yeah
and uh winning them over yeah yeah and
so
and i look i can still win i can i can
go to a comedy club and it's if it's not
my audience i'm not saying everybody
just knows who
yeah you know comics were not it's not
like it's
you know i mean like david spade goes up
you're like yeah everybody knows who
david spade is yeah
but with us it's like yeah our audience
knows but i can easily go
to a lot of people and they have no idea
who yeah yeah yeah uh
but so it's when you do a special it's
gonna be kind of tougher now
to do it in front of a crowd that
doesn't know you yeah
uh and you i mean you want it to i think
i just would want my audience there
now just because we're there but uh
it's like it depends on where you film
it like i don't you know the last one i
filmed
in l.a and this next one when we think
about like
i don't know where i would want you know
possibly san francisco or like i like
filming
in maybe a different place yeah that's
from where i'm at just
just age just to be like you hear this
it's unique what they're hearing
yeah you know if you're a san francisco
comic and you got a comic going up there
doing like some super
progressive like woke stuff they
probably heard versions
of those ideas throughout their life
yeah right maybe throughout their week
right they've heard that take on the
riots or whatever it is yeah but like
when you go tape in a place where they
don't know your perspective
your voice is interesting yeah you know
like what you're saying your opinions
are interesting
they know who you are they're ready for
what you have to do but it's still
refreshing it's like yo
yes this guy's different yeah he's
different and so maybe you don't
win them over but you still get to be
unique
yeah you know to them i hate the winning
them over i'm so glad that's done
that's stupid i [ __ ] it was my least
favorite part of comedy the first three
minutes of comedy sucked
yeah hated it yeah because i have to
like explain my it's like
yeah i would always look at some comics
that they're like a big fat comic could
just be like hey i'm not gonna fall over
on you they'd like do some [ __ ] the
monkey
yeah move the mic so you can see me
exactly like but what it did
is essentially calmed everybody and got
everybody on the same page like i
understand the magic trick that they're
doing
right and but when i would go up there
it's like i'm like i don't want to
[ __ ]
i know what you're thinking yeah like i
don't care about that yeah yeah i just
want to talk about what i want to talk
about unfortunately i have to like
you don't know what i am i jewish am i
[ __ ] italian like nobody understands
like what i am i use some like hip-hop
vernacular so like
there's all this confusion amongst the
strangers so i just have to start out
with a really
funny [ __ ] joke yeah and then
everybody goes okay whatever he is
that's fine yeah you're handcuffed by
your lack of uniqueness in the sense
that you all are just straight white
dudes
like there's like use patrice the
elephant in the room when i walk out
there
yeah well now it's more normal but
before i don't see a lot of comics that
look like this guy yeah
so if i don't address it they're gonna
be like hey buddy yeah it's almost like
a guy like when i would do shows in
harlem i just wouldn't talk about it or
the bronzer whatever night bomb
and then i realized it's like they don't
see people like me outside of the bodega
yeah it's almost like a guy in a
wheelchair going up and just doing jokes
not acknowledging this is not what's
interesting to me about you yeah it's
it's a weird thing it's like a gift and
a curse right yeah
but the gift to finish real quick your
point to your point the gift is
i know exactly what to talk about when i
get up there yeah your curse is
what the [ __ ] do you talk about when you
get what do you think i am yeah
you got an accident at least so
something he's got an italian name nate
bargatzi
yeah and then he goes up there starts
speaking in a southern accent
there's going to be a little confusion
yeah i'm sure you have bits about that
in the beginning
yeah you had a funny joke about uh your
italian family i'm an italian family
yeah i
uh it was do you remember all your old
no
there's something about like he just
stayed there or something yeah it was
like uh
i remember this yeah i i i'm blanking on
now but yeah
we're italian and uh something i don't
know
anyway but like i would think about that
like there were these like like a gay
comic that doesn't present as super gay
yeah that dude's got to come out every
time like the
hardest thing in his life he probably
was coming out oh yeah and every time he
go
hi guys i'm gay and then you got a few
dudes
he hears his parents reaction every time
he gets to relive it
[Laughter]
so i was like i understand how that's
tough but at the same time
and i wonder if like i always wondered
that like with the gay dudes in life if
they lean into the
femininity or whatever that word is of
homosexual
yes like i don't got to explain to you
what i am yeah
like i'm i'm well okay
so you do got to learn so i do think the
benefit i do have is the southern accent
so i mean i was
you didn't change your [ __ ] at all some
people moved to new york and all of a
sudden they started talking like us
yeah and i your accent got stronger it
was worse
yeah like when i first met you you were
just speaking like neutral yeah
by the end it was getting real nate
parker well i
always took it that's another thing i
hated i hated when like southern people
moved
to new york and then they would trash
the south like i'm
i like someone to be proud where i don't
care where you're from but i want you to
love where you're from
yeah that's all i want yeah i don't care
where in the world yeah you're from
yeah just be way on board with you like
love your
home yeah
you